[Música]
quando eu era criança eu adorava a
seletiva e do chip santos vai eu ainda
adoro o simples onde passei e vera e em
particular a que o quinto clipe
antes do episódio e começar um desses
clubes têm a ver com a evolução da vida
como é que nós pensamos da evolução das
das células
cada vez temos organismos mais e mais
complexo até termos realmente o ser
humano atual que neste sábado vocês
podem estar representado pelo o mersin
santos mas há aqui uma questão
fundamental faz falta
neste clip cook é questão da origem da
vida ou seja como é que a primeira
célula que a unidade básica da vida
surgiu e essa questão é fundamental como
você ouvir o norberto eu sou a
astrobióloga esse é exatamente o que o
estudo estudo como é que a vida originou
e vida evoluiu e também se existe vida
em outras partes do nosso sistema solar
e de fato o cientista chave em que é
vida surgiu mais ou menos a cerca de
quatro mil milhões de anos e nós temos
isso temos fósseis mas a grande questão
que está aqui faltar é como é que vida
surgiu na terra qual é o processo os
cientistas têm dados que indicam que as
primeiras células precisaram de água e
moléculas orgânicas um pouquinho como
mex que nós usamos para construir uma
cozinha e em que as moléculas orgânicas
são os nossos lexus ea célula é nossa
casinha e a maioria de vocês deve estar
a pensar esta questão é efetivamente
fácil
as moléculas orgânicas de certeza que
surgiram aqui na terra
por exemplo no fundo dos oceanos em
fontes hidrotermais ricos
toda esta questão da origem da vida é
fácil resolução
mexe tem algo a dizer
de facto os lexus as moléculas orgânicas
fundamentais para construir a nossa
célula tem também uma contribuição extra
terrestre vieram também fora da terra e
sem absolutamente fantástico
e de facto o que nós sabemos é que desde
a formação do nosso sistema solar há
cerca de quatro pontos e seis mil
milhões de anos atrás até 3.8 milhões de
anos
nós aqui na terra vimos essas moléculas
orgânicas é serem trazidas para a terra
e como é que nós cheguemos isso temos
máquinas do tempo
aí vocês devem estar a pensar máquinas
do tempo nas máquinas do tempo não
existem não é fato existem e nós
cientistas no ranking da astrobiologia
temos acesso a máquinas do tempo que nós
chamamos de meteoritos e os trouxe
alguns desses meteoritos juriti chão
rochas extraterrestres que vieram a
maioria delas da cintura de asteróides
que se situa entre marte e júpiter
ye elas este meteoritos passaram pela
atmosfera terrestre guia tornaram a
nossa no nosso sol aqui na terra não
devem ser confundidos com meteoros que é
o que nós chamamos de estrelas cadentes
porque nesse caso o o hoje as amostras é
queimaram completamente e nós não temos
amostras
alguns desses meteoritos permaneceram e
não trato desde a formação do nosso
sistema solar
e essas são as verdadeiras máquinas do
tempo e essas máquinas do tempo estão
cheias de moléculas orgânicas por
exemplo com estes direitos muito
pequeninos que o trouxe
e se uns as verdadeiras máquinas do
tempo são elas que estão cheias de
moléculas orgânicas e por isso quando eu
analiso no laboratório e tem que ter a
certeza que elas não estão contaminadas
como elas aqui da terra portanto é
importantíssimo que quando recolhemos
muito querido aqui na terra
temos a certeza que não estamos a
contaminar e há vários locais
aqui na terra que os cientistas podem ir
e recolher é um dos muitos geeks o nosso
carro favorito
é a antártida e porque por duas grandes
razões primeiro que tudo o gelo e branco
jurisdições curso portanto é fácil ver é
os meteoritos é a razão óbvia
a segunda questão tem a ver que é hoje
ao dar partida vai agir como um grande
congelador que vai preservar os
meteoritos e todas as moléculas
orgânicas e portanto vai permanecer as
moléculas orgânicas extraterrestres não
residentes sem serem contaminadas
eu posso dizer que eu analiso juriti no
laboratório e é um assunto absolutamente
fascinante
não só porque são amostras extra testas
mas também porque estas amostras chão
essas amostras mais velhas que ela um
dia qualquer um nós pode tocar e por
isso achei tanto carinho e objetos da
tradição tão tão velho chão do tempo da
formação do nosso sistema solar mas no
meu caso eu tô preocupada com as
moléculas orgânicas que são fundamentais
por origem da vida na terra e eu posso
dizer quando analisa este meteorito
viajar para trás do tempo o tempo em que
o nosso sistema solar foi formado e vai
exatamente como elas orgânicas estão
presentes por exemplo toda esta questão
com muitos nós nos posicionamos de como
é que surgiu a água dos nossos oceanos
eu posso dizer que nós sentíssemos agora
dados que mostram que a água dos nossos
oceanos foi entregue por estes por estas
amostras por estas máquinas do tempo
além disso muitos desses meteoritos
quando análises no laboratório tem um
share muito característico muito
sulfuroso estever cujas moléculas
orgânicas que estão presentes mas já
temos aqui muitas peças do paso que
tenta responder esta questão da origem
da vida
só pra começar e para tentar construir o
padrão
sabemos que o nosso sistema solar surgiu
a 4.6 milhões de anos e sabemos disso
por causa das nossas máquinas do tempo e
desde aí até 3.8 milhões de anos houve
um grande bombardeamento por parto
direitos e as moléculas orgânicas de
peças foram trazidas para a terra
logo depois mais ou menos
a 4 milhões de anos a vida surgiu
é importante ver nisto é que não só o
júri que nos visitaram mas há outros
corpos celestes que também nos visitaram
desde então eles são chamados de cometas
é que vocês podem ver nestes lights é um
capítulo do século 11 em que não se está
o cometa halley o cometa halley setores
no século 11 e desde então temos
visitado frequentemente é importante
referir que cometas não são tigres são
completamente diferentes dos cometas são
chamados bola chutes de gelo e como o
nome indica são compostos por região e
por muitas muitas moléculas orgânicas
extraterrestre no direito vai além dos
confins do nosso sistema solar e
importante tem uma origem completamente
diferentes dos dos asteróides e dos
meteoritos e como é que nós sabemos que
os cometas tão cheio de moléculas
orgânicas mas há duas maneiras
os cometas nos visitam e nós apontamos
dos copos eventos exatamente por
moléculas orgânicas é que estão
presentes ou então somos nós que vamos
visitar os cometas e posso dizer que
houve uma missão recentemente a agência
espacial européia e que basicamente nós
fomos visitar um cometa chamado de 67 p
demais chamadas churyumov gerasimenko
teu nome estará incompleto e que nós
vimos aqui se cometa estavam cheios de
moléculas orgânicas com muitas muitas
muitas algumas delas fundamentais por
origem da vida no nosso planeta e que
está tão tão importante vai dar-nos
pistas não só acerca da origem da vida
mas também das pistas acerca por exemplo
como é que o cometa chora e uma das
questões é ok então como é com cometa
cheira será que tem cheiro ou não
aprovado o cometa é uma das hipóteses
seria com o cometa não tem cheiro porque
o espaço não achar mas isto está errado
de facto o cometa cheio de moléculas
orgânicas e essas moléculas orgânicas dá
um cheiro o cometa esse bonde pode ser
aqui a gente cometa teriam
o cheiro mais agradável chegaria a
flores em particular a rosas e tulipas
mas também neste caso isso não é verdade
este cometa 67/p tem um cheiro bastante
desagradável xará off podres e amêndoas
amargas e como é que nós tivemos isto
tem a ver novamente com os analistas
fizeram e se cometa é detetar um chinês
de hidrogênio que é o que é uma molécula
que dá um cheiro típico de amêndoas
amargas e também de tentarmos sulfureto
de hidrogênio que é o cheiro típico ovos
podres portanto quando algum amigo voto
se perguntar então como é que um cometa
chera vocês já sabem podem dizer que era
mesmo muito muito maior que o cheiro é
muito agradável está off podres e
amêndoas amargas toda esta questão
obviamente o que eu estou a tentar
mostrar é que os cometas os meteoritos
trouxeram as moléculas orgânicas
terrestre tiveram um papel fundamental
porém da vila e mas é essa a origem da
vida aqui na terra tanto que nós
cientistas pensamos é que noutros locais
do nosso sistema solar é vida também
pode ser sujeito e o candidato ideal é
marca o planeta por mário é o movimento
que que nós tivemos e temos dados que
indicam que só por exemplo os meteoritos
entregaram quantidades astronômicas
muitas e muitas toneladas todos os anos
de carbono e portanto essas agências
espaciais todo o mundo estão em
ferramenta à procura desse carbono e
tentar ver se existe vida extraterrestre
ao planeta marte tem qualquer missão
especial futura é os instrumentos vão
ter que me que tudo uma câmera porque se
existe vida extraterrestre em marte nós
podemos ver mas na realidade os
cientistas não estão à espera de
encontrar o mesmo dos verdes no planeta
vermelho essa é a verdade
é o que nós andamos à procura são
pequenos cheiros microorganismos e são
as formas de vida que nós estamos à
espera de encontrar no planeta vermelho
outros locais no nosso sistema solar
onde a vida pode ter existido devido à
entrega de moléculas orgânicas é uma luz
lado de júpiter chamada europa ela é
esta
o tema superfície gelada com alguns
impactos mas é novidade o importante
desta desta lua é que nós cheguemos que
existe um oceano com água por baixo
daquela camada de gelo e tentei muito
impressiva formas de vida am denar
nesses ocian outra lua também muito
semelhante mas neste caso é uma lua
chamada de índice alto
é uma lua de saturno é também é chamada
tem uma superfície gelada e novamente
tem um oceano de água líquida por baixo
dessa camada de gelo e nós tivemos que
existe um oceano porque foi possível
observar os gases que saem dessa lua e
ea composição desses gastos é que mostra
que há muitas e muitas moléculas
orgânicas movimento que estamos aqui a
falar da origem da vida no nosso sistema
solar fora do nosso sistema solar e em
outros sistemas solares é também
possível que cometas e meteoritos tenham
entrega moléculas orgânicas fundamentais
para a vida
e de fato os cientistas têm dados que
apontam que há um sistema solar há
alguns anos no desenvolvimento do nosso
mas que tem outra estrela que não o
nosso sol em que há planetas a orbitar
em a volta de sol e em que é muito fácil
ver que existem cometas e meteoritos e
bombardearem esses planetas nesse outro
sistema solar
portanto a probabilidade da vida também
ter surgido neste outro sistema solar é
muito muito grande
continuando o movimento aqui só falar de
alguns sistemas solares numa galáxia com
você chave existem milhões e milhões de
galáxias no nosso universo e portanto
nós temos que ver é para onde é que
cometas e meteoritos irão viajar tu nós
chegamos aqui no nosso sistema solar mas
de certeza que fora do nosso sistema
solar em outras galáxias cometas e
meteoritos terão viajado
nós temos certeza absoluta é que as
moléculas fundamentais para a origem da
vida e para a formação da primeira
célula unidade básica
vida trave indo e tem uma contribuição é
extraterrestre e sabemos também que
essas moléculas orgânicas slap
fundamentais para a vida são espalhados
por todo o universo o que mostra
claramente que nos barreiras por origem
da vida na terra
portanto se nós sabemos agora o impacto
e norma que cometa saint moritz tiveram
aqui na terra imaginem no resto do
universo
[Aplausos]